[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
diciendo nocturna ustedes Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
la comunidad internacional condenó el
ataque perpetrado en una sinagoga A las
afueras de Jerusalén este en el que al
menos siete personas perdieron la vida y
otras diez resultaron heridas los hechos
ocurren tras la mortal redada realizada
por Israel en la que nueve palestinos
fallecieron en
el mundo conmemoró del aniversario
número 78 de la liberación del campo de
concentración de
la fecha coincidió con las acusaciones
verbales entre los presidentes de Rusia
y Ucrania Vladimir Putin acusó a las
autoridades de kiev de neonazis a su
turno que dijo que seguirá luchando
contra el odio
la administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de Estados Unidos propuso
que los homosexuales y bisexuales puedan
donar sangre si se encuentran en una
relación monógama por ahora estas
personas debían esperar tres meses desde
su última relación sexual para donar
tenemos análisis
[Aplausos]
[Música]
damos inicio en Jerusalén este porque al
menos siete personas fallecieron tras un
ataque en una sinagoga de la ciudad las
autoridades calificaron el tiroteo de
ataque terrorista e informaron que
mataron al responsable los hechos se
presentan Solo un día después de las
mortales redadas del ejército israelí en
yin que dejaron Al menos nueve víctimas
el Primer Ministro Israel y Benjamín que
visitó el lugar aseguró que habrá
represalias Yanira Gómez Muñoz
corresponsal de France 24 nos abrió la
información el tiroteo de esta noche en
una sinagoga de Jerusalén está ocupado
es uno de los ataques más mortíferos de
los últimos años según la policía
israelí el atacante identificado como un
residente palestino de Jerusalén este
llegó sobre las 8:15 de la noche a una
congregación en nevellacov y allí abrió
Fuego contra creyentes que salían del
lugar tras los rezos de inicio del
shabat que recordemos es el día semanal
de oración para los judíos y un momento
de mucha concurrencia en todas las
sinagogas luego Este joven de 21 años
huyó de lugar hacia el barrio palestino
de beijanina donde murió por disparos de
la policía que ha tildado este ataque de
terrorista y ha estado luego rastreando
la zona en busca de posibles Cómplices
no obstante los Testigos han denunciado
que los oficiales respondieron de forma
tardía y también reprocharon al ministro
de seguridad nacional y tamar que se
acercó hasta el lugar y mientras
intentaba hablar se pudieron Escuchar
allí gritos de muerte a los árabes este
ataque ha sido celebrado tanto por la
yihat islámica Palestina como jamás el
portavoz de este último grupo catalogó
ese tiroteo de una respuesta al crimen
cometido por la ocupación en yening En
referencia a la redada israelí que este
jueves dejó nueve palestinos muertos
entre ellos dos civiles y es que han
sido 48 horas de mucha violencia con la
muerte de otro palestino en la represión
de unas protestas en el Ram el
lanzamiento de cohetes de la yihad desde
gaza el bombardeo israelí en la franja
además además de protestas y
enfrentamientos dentro de la propia
ciudad vieja de Jerusalén y a esto se
suma que la autoridad Palestina haya
suspendido la cooperación en seguridad
con Israel lo que supone entre otros que
las fuerzas palestinas no están
informadas de las operaciones israelíes
en cisjordania mientras el mundo
conmemoró este 27 de enero El
Aniversario 78 de la liberación del
campo de concentración de ashvich los
presidentes Ruso y ucraniano
aprovecharon la fecha para intercambiar
acusaciones Vladimir Putin señaló
nuevamente a las autoridades de Ucrania
de ser neonazis mientras que bolodimir
selenski afirmó seguir luchando contra
el odio mientras continúa la guerra en
su país Gabriel colchón tiene los
detalles
[Música]
recordó a las víctimas del holocausto
encendió una vela en babillar en las
afueras de kiev donde los nazis
ejecutaron a más de 33.500 judíos en
1941 también llamó a combatir la
indiferencia y el haciendo referencia a
la guerra en su propio país
La indiferencia y el odio son siempre
capaces de crear el mal Solo Juntos por
eso es tan importante que todos los que
valoran la vida muestren determinación
cuando se trata de salvar a quienes el
odio pretende destruir
la fecha para reiterar sus argumentos
señalando nuevamente a las autoridades
ucranianassis y de cometer crímenes
contra civiles uno de los motivos con
los que justificó su intervención en
Ucrania el olvido de las lecciones de la
historia conduce la repetición de
Terribles tragedias prueba de ellos son
los crímenes contra civiles las
limpiezas étnicas y las acciones
punitivas cometidos por los neonazis en
Ucrania contra ese mal luchan ahora
valerosamente hombro con hombro nuestros
soldados a la guerra de palabras se
contrapone la del terreno según el
embajador ucraniano en Francia distintos
países han prometido el envío de 321
tanques de guerra Incluyendo los
deseados leopardos de Alemania y los 31
abrams estadounidenses Polonia anunció
este viernes que mandará otros 60
tanques además de los 14 leopardo
alemanes que ya había prometido Canadá
llegó que enviará cuatro de ellos en el
frente el presidente ucraniano describe
la situación como extremadamente aguda
particularmente en donetsky ahora que
presiona para recibir aviones de combate
f-16 pero sus socios occidentales se
niegan en hacerlo argumentando que
llevaría la guerra a un nuevo nivel a
continuación otras noticias destacadas
del día en France 24
las autoridades de Oakland la ciudad más
poblada de Nueva Zelanda declararon el
estado de emergencia debido a las
lluvias torrenciales e inundaciones de
las últimas horas miles de viviendas
escuelas supermercados e incluso la
terminal de pasajeros del aeropuerto se
vieron seriamente afectadas por las
lluvias
entre tanto en Madagascar la tormenta
tropical chineso dejó 16 personas
muertas a su paso por esta Isla africana
las autoridades indicaron que miles de
personas han sido desplazadas de sus
hogares se calcula que unas 14.500
viviendas fueron destruidas por las
intensas lluvias
y el clima también hizo estragos en
Argentina 90 personas heridas y una
fallecida dejó un inesperado temporal
que gran de granizo que azotó la
provincia de San Luis un frente frío que
atraviesa el territorio argentino
también provocó Fuertes lluvias en
Buenos Aires y otras provincias en donde
hubo inundaciones cortes del suministro
eléctrico y cierre de rutas
la administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de Estados Unidos propuso
que los hombres homosexuales o
bisexuales que estén en una relación
monógama y que solo hayan tenido
relaciones sexuales con su pareja
estable Durante los últimos tres meses
puedan donar sangre previamente estas
personas debían esperar un año tras su
última relación sexual para ser
elegibles este tiempo cambió hasta los
tres meses para analizar este tema
conectamos con Ilan shapiro médico
especializado en salud pública
Bienvenido a France 24 porque esta
propuesta llega en este momento qué
condiciones han cambiado
un par de cosas la información que ya
tenemos el día de hoy es que en un
principio están realmente teniendo una
política que discriminaba contra una
grupo específico ya han habido muchas
artículos científicos muchas
investigaciones donde prueban que
realmente todos los estereotipos que se
tenían de más cantidad de hiv de otras
cosas más pues que realmente no podían
comportarse con todas las personas de la
misma manera que hay grupos que se
pueden Designar que tienen más HB y
otras enfermedades sexualmente
transmisibles hay grupos también
heterosexuales que también tienen los
mismos riesgos y no se le aplican las
mismas leyes bueno Cuáles son las
pruebas de rigor que se realizan previo
a una donación de sangre para comprobar
que la persona está sana
de entradas se Checa para h&b todas las
enfermedades importantes que se pueden
transmitir por medio de la sangre esta
idea era en un principio crear y
disminuir los riesgos que una persona
que al momento de darles Esa esa unidad
de sangre va a poder estar sanos en este
momento sabemos que tenemos una
disminución de donantes tenemos muchas
cosas que están pasando en el mundo y
sobre todo con Kobe 19 muchos de los
bancos de sangre están teniendo
problemas para poder atender eso y por
eso teniendo la evidencia científica y
además la importancia de tener ese banco
de sangre listo para cualquier momento
que cualquier área de nosotros
necesitemos necesitamos ampliar y seguir
ahora sí no no los estereotipos sino lo
que realmente dice la ciencia podríamos
considerar esta de alguna forma una
iniciativa que busca luchar contra la
estigmatización
que en forma personal definitivamente
porque una persona que lleva una pareja
sin importar si es hombre hombre mujer
hombre mujer o cualquier definición que
tengamos Pues realmente tiene los mismos
riesgos que cualquier otra persona más
lógicamente Si una persona heterosexual
tiene múltiples parejas también
incrementa su riesgo entonces de esta
manera estamos poniendo algo de de
equidad algo de de Justicia para que
podamos tener todos la misma oportunidad
de donar sangre pues Señor chafiro usted
muchas gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en France 24 un
placer como siempre en otras noticias
cientos de personas se manifestaron en
las calles de San Salvador la capital de
El Salvador en contra de la Reforma
pensionaria que fue aprobada por el
congreso el pasado mes de diciembre la
modificación involucra seis artículos de
la ley integral del sistema de pensiones
organizaciones aseguran que la reforma
afecta a las personas y solo beneficia a
los fondos privados
San Salvador fue testigo de la marcha
negra así se denominó la manifestación
de 500 personas en la capital del país
Quienes se movilizaron en contra de la
aprobación de seis artículos de la ley
integral del sistema de pensiones
sindicalistas trabajadores y miembros de
organizaciones sociales se dirigieron a
la casa presidencial en oposición a la
reforma Qué es mentira que la pensión
mínima es de 400
dólares estamos protestando porque esas
son pensiones miserables para nosotros
además de los trabajadores
organizaciones no gubernamentales
también expresaron su preocupación por
la política de gobierno de nayib bukele
como es el caso del instituto
centroamericano de estudios Fiscales
quien cuestionó los métodos del
ejecutivo y la sustentabilidad
financiera del cambio
para el Instituto las reformas
presentadas por el ejecutivo no dan una
respuesta integrada a los problemas
estructurales del sistema de pensiones
en términos de cobertura suficiencia
equidad y sostenibilidad
esta controvertida legislación forma
parte del paquete presentado por el
gobierno en septiembre de 2021 y que
otorga el manejo de recursos a las
administradoras de fondo de pensiones a
pesar de las solicitudes de
nacionalización de algunos sindicatos
según los datos de sefi 8 de cada 10
personas adultas mayores actualmente no
tienen acceso a una pensión y solo una
de cuatro tienen un trabajo remunerado
que ingresan en el sistema provisional
asuntos no tratados en la reforma en
Estados Unidos la policía de San
Francisco publicó este viernes el video
en que se puede ver el ataque con
cuchillo a Paul pelosi esposo de la
expresidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi en octubre
de 2022 las imágenes de la cámara
corporal de la policía se publicaron
junto con un video de vigilancia que
muestra el rompiendo una ventana de
vidrio para ingresar a la vivienda de la
pareja en San Francisco más tarde en las
imágenes de la policía muestran el
momento en que el agresor retiene a
pelosi y lo golpea con un martillo
el nombre de toda mi familia seguimos
Agradeciendo a las personas por todas
las oraciones que nos continúan enviando
preguntando sobre el progreso que está
teniendo mi esposo él está progresando
pero tomará más tiempo como saben hoy se
dio a conocer cierta información
no he oído la llamada al 911 no he oído
la confesión no he visto el allanamiento
cambiamos de tema y vamos a Perú porque
el congreso aceptó reabrir el debate
para decidir si las elecciones previstas
Para abril de 2024 se realizan en
diciembre de 2023 el pronunciamiento se
produjo tras una acalorada discusión en
el legislativo luego de que la
presidenta Dina boluarte volviera a
llamar al adelanto de los comicios y que
el presidente de la comisión de
Constitución Hernando guerra García
hiciera la petición en estos momentos
justamente el congreso debate un posible
adelanto de las elecciones
desde el ejecutivo habíamos planteado
para que estas elecciones se adelanten a
abril del 2024
proyecto que en el congreso se agotó una
primera vez y estaba se está esperando
la votación de la segunda vez sin
embargo
las marchas de protesta continúan
hay más bloqueos
hay más violencia y violencia así
llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América en France 24 ustedes Les
agradecemos su sintonía y los invitamos
a continuar con nosotros que ya llega
Natalia Cabrera con toda la información
del continente americano en aquí América
feliz noche para todos
[Música]